à cette guerre jette chaque jour sur les
routes des milliers de civils certains
partent se mettre à l'abri à l'ouest
dans la région de lviv notamment
d'autres font le choix de quitter
l'ukraine 2 million d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants ont pour leurs fruits le
pays un chiffre communiqué par le haut
commissariat des nations unies des
civils qui se réfugient dans les états
voisins comme la pologne ou encore la
hongrie vous en rangs très justement
julia du monde bonjour à vous jusqu'à
merci d'être avec nous journalistes au
sein d'un faux migrants des équipes
d'infos migrants et leurs précieux
travail qui nous est essentiel ici en
sites partenaires de 2 france 24 quelle
a été la situation que vous avez
constaté lorsque vous étiez en hongrie
la situation henry est assez mouvementée
parce que ce sont tout de même des
centaines de personnes qui arrivent
chaque jour dans le pays vous le disiez
tout à l'heure ce sont déjà 2 millions
de personnes qui ont quitté l'ukraine et
sur sur ce nombre se sont déjà plus de
180 mille personnes qui ont qui sont
arrivés en hongrie donc depuis le 24
février alors il faut savoir que la
hongrie a 5 postes frontières avec avec
l'ukraine le principal est la ville de
zahran il est accessible uniquement par
train alors les déplacés ils arrivent
directement de la ville ukrainienne de
chuck qui est vraiment la dernière avant
la frontière et en raison de cela ce les
arrivées sont vraiment souvent chargé
d'émotion parce que ce sont les les
premiers moments des personnes loin de
la guerre on a vu des personnes arrivées
en larmes ou fondre en larmes sur le
quai de la gare en retrouvant leurs
proches qui étaient qui étaient venus
les chercher les personnes sont aussi
très fatigué par des jours de voyage
parmi ces personnes on l'a vu également
dans les autres pays frontaliers
beaucoup de femmes avec enfants des
personnes âgées mais aussi beaucoup
d'étudiants étrangers nous avons
notamment rencontré james qui était qui
et nigérians étudiants en médecine à
kiev il a quitté kiev avec un groupe
d'amis il était très très très ému de
nous raconter le soulagement d'avoir
passé la frontière et ce sentiment de
sécurité qu'il ressentait enfin après
des jours véritablement en danger alors
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui partent ou un point de
chute soit hongrie soit dans un pays
étranger nous avons notamment rencontré
galina qui est ici avec son fils pacha
ils partent tous les deux vers lisbonne
au portugal où ils ont des proches qui
vont pouvoir les accueillir mais ce ne
sera peut-être plus le cas dans les mois
à venir et ça c'est un petit peu
inquiétant peut-être que les prochains
ukrainien qui vont partir eux seront un
petit peu plus seuls ils ont moins de
solutions d'hébergement après leur
sortie du véhicule mais parce que le
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban
qui avait un temps pour de précédents
conflits n'avait pas été franchement
disposé à accueillir des des réfugiés a
semble-t-il changé d'avis cette fois
avec l'ukraine mais comment est-ce que
les hongrois la population civile
clairement réagit elle de son côté alors
les hongrois se montre vraiment très
très accueillants et sont très organisés
dans cet accueil en fait actuellement
c'est toute la logistique qui repose sur
temps pour l'hébergement que la
restauration des personnes ça repose
vraiment sur la société civile et les
municipalités c'est une très bonne chose
mais c'est un petit peu inquiétant aussi
parce que tous ces bénévoles commencent
à fatiguer et nous somme d'à peine deux
semaines du début du conflit on se
demande c'est qu'il va se passer dans
les semaines et les mois à venir alors
le dans les villes frontalières de
l'ukraine des centres d'hébergement ont
ouvert c'est le cas à zao n'y met aussi
à l'honneur à à belek sourani dans ses
posts france ces postes frontières sont
aussi des toutes petites villes il faut
se rendre compte ces quelques centaines
d'habitants donc la logistique n'est pas
simple à mettre en place et on y
organise malgré tout des distributions
de nourriture de beaucoup de matériel
pour bébé parce que beaucoup de
personnes arrivent avec de très jeunes
enfants et en organise aussi le
transport vert à rogne pour pour prendre
le train en direction de budapest c'est
le c'est le cas de beaucoup de personnes
au sein de ses bénévoles beaucoup
d'endroits veulent vraiment aider on a
vu des personnes qui ont fait plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres en voiture pour
apporter des dons qui leur avait été qui
leur a été remis à budapest la situation
est un petit peu différente les
personnes restent plus longtemps et donc
l'urgence c'est vraiment de trouver un
hébergement citoyens pour pour quelques
jours pour que les personnes puissent un
petit peu se reposer on a rencontré
mohamed et sa femme alona lorsqu'ils
sont arrivés à budapest il ne savais pas
du tout où aller ils ont pu être
hébergée quelques jours dans une famille
american aux hongroises pour reprendre
pour reprendre quelques forces tandis
que les déplacés non nous craignent un
sont accueillis de la même manière dans
le pays alors oui ils sont accueillis de
la même manière dans le pays mais en
fait les nonnes ukrainiens sont bien
souvent des étudiants étrangers qui
cherchent à partir assez vite certains
d'entre eux sont pris en charge par les
autorités de leur pays mais ça peut
vraiment être variable d'un pays à
l'autre donc ça dépend des nationalités
en revanche sur le plan de la protection
il y a eu un changement entériné
aujourd'hui en hongrie avec l'adoption
d'un décret qui exclut les unes des nues
craignant de la protection temporaire
européenne alors cette protection elle
permet dans leur maman de séjourner dans
l'union européenne pendant un an
renouvelable du travail et d'avoir accès
à un hébergement de ce fait les ong
hongrois sont aujourd'hui assez
inquiètes du sort des personnes qui
seraient sortis d'ukraine qui se
trouverait en hongrie et qui n'auraient
pas forcément la possibilité de
retourner directement dans leur pays on
ne sait pas exactement encore quel sera
leur sort merci beaucoup julien on peut
peut-être suivre aussi justement vous
suivez vous allez garder contact avec
ces gens vous allez rencontrer on peut
retrouver de leur nouvelle sur le site
d'info oui absolument mettre déjà tous
nos reportages et sont publiés et
d'autres dans les semaines à venir c'est
bien sûr une situation qu'on va suivre
de très près merci à vous merci encore à
berre